okay so falcon in the winter soldier has
now finished its full season
and in this video i thought we'd take a
look back over the series to break down
every easter egg
hidden detail and bit of trivia that we
could find
we open with sam channeling his inner
iron man and getting ready to take the
shield to the smithsonian
it's being carried in the same bag as
steve gave him at the end of avengers
end game
and him putting it away whereas steve
took it out very much shows his
mentality towards it
this scene is interlaced between a
mission in which he took down the laf
who are led by batroc the lieber batroc
can be seen wearing clothing coloured
purple and yellow
which he not only done throughout the
season but is also very similar to what
he wore in the winter soldier
these colours actually call back to his
costumes in the comics
which were always purple and yellow sam
communicates with redwing through an
inner ear link up device
and this is actually a play on the
source material as in that
red wing was a real falcon that he could
telepathically communicate with
we're also introduced to joaquin torres
who in the source material becomes
falcon when sam becomes cap
in this episode he takes a lot of
interest in red wing and the series ends
with him waiting in the wings
by waiting with sam's wings when it
comes to falcon
two can play that game and according to
comments made by series creator malcolm
spellman
you can expect to see him back in the
mcu2 now the laf take to the sky
and end up wearing dark green jump suits
with yellow stripes down them
these are very similar hydra's uniform
from the comics and with valentina
allegra defontaine
aka madame hydra showing up in the
season it could be foreshadowing their
return
waking torres talks about the flag
smashes and we learn they're led by
carly morgenthau
who is a gender swap of carl morgenthau
aka
flag smasher in the comics at the
smithsonian we see sam donate the shield
and he and rody take a stroll through
the captain america exhibit
here we can see that the bucky section
has now been expanded
and it includes a bit about his time as
the winter soldier as well as the
sokovia records
in the list of the vanished we can catch
the name victoria alonso
who is a producer at marvel studios they
go up to a wall of captain america
propaganda
and we can see a poster of steve saying
i want you
sam stands directly in front of this
giving a nod to how steve
chose him to bear the mantle there's
also a picture of steve from the first
avenger holding a taxi door
and if we go back to that film we can
actually see the woman who snapped this
image
standing in the crowd amongst these
posters is the comic in which cat
punched hitler
and huge shout outs to ryan arie at
screen crush for pointing out that kids
read this in the first adventure
however and and this is where it gets
good bucky was removed from this cover
because
in the comics he was his teen sidekick
whereas that wasn't set up in the mcu
now i still hate that lad now we see
sam's reflection when he stares at the
shield
and he doesn't quite line up with it
this is very similar to imagery from
into the spider-verse
in which miles morales didn't quite meet
the mask when he first came face to face
with it
however by the end of the film his head
did line up
and now that doesn't happen in the
series it does give the starting point
that sam doesn't view himself as being
worthy
cut to winter soldier on a mission and
at first we don't know if this is the
pastor present
this is very similar to how bucky was
introduced in the graphic novel sam
wilson captain america
and in it it was thought for a while
that he had turned back to being evil
bucky wakes up on the floor which is a
call back to when steve and sam talked
about how they had difficulty sleeping
on a mattress at the start of the winter
soldier
in episode 5 bucky manages to sleep on
something comfy at sam's house
showing how he is finally starting to be
at peace with himself
and all the illegal things that he did
see eagle pudding there bucky goes to
therapy
and we discover that he's been trying to
make amends now this scene in which you
see a man and woman in a car
felt very similar in setup in the way
that it was shot to the murder of the
starks
which was also by the hands of bucky
whereas in that he killed howard before
moving on to maria
here he just hits the guy in the face
and leans in the window to tell the
senator that he's changed
in the book of names there are a couple
of notes including a rostov
who is the marvel villain the red
barbarian we learn that this is steve's
notebook
and whereas he was using it to list
things to catch up on in the present
bucky is very much still stuck in the
past occurred to him in brooklyn
which is where he and steve grew up as
kids he breaks up a fight in an alley
over a trash can
which is similar to how he broke up a
fight in an alley involving steve
who is using a trash can lid it's a
reach now cut to sam going home
and we see his parents boat is called
paul and darlene
which were their names in the comics the
story of the boat is very much a
metaphor for the shield
as sam and his family want to get rid of
it at first
as they don't think they can live up to
its legacy it's got a lot of bad things
going on with it
and that point seems destroyed beyond
repair however they realize it can still
stand as something great
and when people pull together to make
something positive they can do it
sam and his sister end up keeping the
boat in the end and going forward with
it
much like how he does with the shield
even though initially it seems like a
burden
get it bird burden hey come on now that
was good
now black sweatshirt attack happens and
after torres tells sam
we see that he's watching the news
station whi h
which is the mcu network that has
appeared in several movies
we're introduced to captain white boy
summer aka john
take a walk on the wild side who's one
of the worst people in the world
now speaking of worst people in the
world i've just realized i haven't
introduced myself
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose bird
puns are poetry in motion
and if you find this video exciting then
please click the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel because i can do breakdowns like
this all day
i'll jump to episode 2 and we open with
john walker in his old high school
locker room
here he's joined by his wife olivia and
the scene itself feels like it was
ripped right out of the
comics it echoes the one from the first
avenger
just before steve went out on a mission
and in both shots the captain america
character
is sat down doubting whether they can do
it and they're joined by the woman that
they love who stood up and reassuring
them
we're also introduced to a sidekick
battle star who similar to his comic
book counterpart has a large star on his
chest
kinda sucks we'll never get that battle
star funko pop as i did want one
but i suppose in the end he did end up
as a bobble head
sorry that was so bad anyway we hear a
marching band playing a rearrangement of
the star-spangled man with a plan
which you might remember from steve's
propaganda tour in the first avenger
walker's uniform doesn't have the white
in it that steve's did
and symbolically this shows a lack of
innocence however his usage suit
does end up getting it potentially
showcasing how the character has changed
his first interview takes place on abc's
good morning
america which just so happens to be
owned by disney
walker is seen training with the shield
and in the comics it took him a while
before he was able to use it properly
he ended up having to be taught by
taskmaster who we now know is
popping up in black widow sam would like
to do something similar in episode 5
and use pads as a way to throw it as a
projectile cut to sam and bucky meeting
at the air force base
and the pair want to quack the case sam
uses the term the big three which means
androids aliens and wizards
and this is a nod to the three enemies
that the avengers have fought
with them being ultron thanos and loki
on the plane bucky asks sam what his
plan is before he jumps out of it
and this mirrors the conversation
between steve and tony and the avengers
cap asked tony what his plan of attack
was and he replied with
i have a plan attack bucky then jumps
out the plane with a parachute
which is a nod to when steve did it at
the start of the winter soldier
sam also mocks him and says he got it on
camera
which could be a reference to shuri
doing something similar to t'challa in
the black panther
the name the white wolf is also brought
up which isn't known to the post credit
scene of that movie
we see bucky doing his super fast
running to catch up to the semi trucks
and this was of course displayed in the
tunnel scene chase from civil war
walker and hoskins swoop in to save the
day and later they picked sam and bucky
up on the road
bucky asks him if he ever jumped on a
grenade which is a nod to when steve did
it in the first avenger
walker says that he's done it four times
but states that he used his helmet
showing that he wasn't in any real
danger interestingly in that scene we
can also catch peggy running towards the
grenade
showing that she was willing to
sacrifice herself too
this could set up the what if story that
is set to debut in summer
in which she becomes captain america
instead of steve
sam and bucky travel to meet isaiah
bradley and beforehand they come across
his grandson eli
who in the comics becomes a hero known
as the patriot
isaiah's origins very much play upon the
tuskegee sevilla study
which was a systemically racist
experiment that involved the government
lying about treating the disease in
black people
so that they could study the long-term
effects of it instead of treating it
they merely used placebos
and this allowed people where there to
go on and infect others
whilst also giving them things like
blindness deafness and death
it's a horrible chapter in human history
and something that was brought up in the
graphic novel of truth
which centered around isaiah's journey
truth is the title of episode 5
and in that isaiah mentions the 332nd
which is also the name of the tuskegee
air force
in that entry isaiah brings up how he
saved a number of pows
and was jailed for it this juxtaposes
steve's journey who did the same thing
in world war ii
and was instead praised as a hero
outside we get a scene in which sam is
accosted by the police
and in the next one we see that the
opposite thing happens with walker
when he's asked to take selfies with
them the episode ends with bucky and sam
going to zemo
and we can see that his cell number is
2187 which
just so happened to be layers on the
death star in a new hope
jump to episode 3 and we see walker
acting on
pheasant when interrogating someone not
not an easter egg there just a crap pun
now bucky goes to zemo and we see him
uttering the mind control words from
civil war
this scene mirrors the silence of the
lambs in not only the setup of the pair
looking at each other through glass
but also the ark that they go on like
bucky clarice went to a criminal for
help
and said criminal ended up escaping much
like how zemo does
zemo ends up looking a lot more like his
comic book counterpart than he did in
civil war and not only does he get his
purple mask but he also wears a coat
with a fur pattern on it
that's extremely similar to the source
material on the plane they end up
discussing the marvin gaye album
troubleman
which is what sam played to steve at the
end of the winter soldier when he was in
hospital
kurta carly at the grchq and we see her
visit mamadonia
in her hands she holds a hamza which in
religion provides protection from the
evil eye
a wall marking for the power broker at
one point appears in madrid
and the symbols used are the characters
eyes this sign itself is playing on the
phrase big brother is watching you
which comes from george orwell's 1984.
there are theories that i've done deep
dives on which talk about how
sharon wasn't the original power broker
and
this sign it definitely seems to lend
itself to that in madrapua we see that
sam is pretending to be the smiling
tiger
a villain from the comics that ended up
hiding out in the city at one point
they go to the bronze monkey which in
the source material
has been called both that as well as the
brass monkey saloon
there's also the princess bar which was
wolverine's home away from home
any time that he visited the city not
long after that they're taken to selby
who may be playing on suzanne salby from
the comics
sharon carter kills her using a sniper
rifle which is riffing on the comics in
which she too used one when tracking the
winter soldier
at her apartment we see the best dance
moves that we've ever seen
which is so good that marvel had to
release an hour long cut
of zemo going off hashtag released the
zemo cut and hashtag restore this snyder
versus scumbag no it's not your fault
marvel
shortly after they go to nagel a
scientist who's ripped straight out of
isaiah bradley's origin story the truth
in that he injected him with super
soldier serum whereas
here we learn that he extracted it from
his dna in order to duplicate it
after a shootout they go to leave and
sam says to bucky
you're not gonna move your seat up are
you this is a play on civil war in which
the positions were reversed
and sam refused to move his forward the
journey to latvia
a real location that dr doom's home
latviria
is playing upon after a run-in with io
we see flashbacks of their past together
in wakanda
and bucky does a trial by fire where she
attempts to activate him
he is however free and we can hear the
music in the background change from the
winter soldier theme
to a more hopeful one as he gains
control
at zemo's hq they discuss the idea of
supremacy
and how those that seek to become
superhumans will be corrupted by it
this foreshadows john walker's arc in
the episode
and also callies throughout the season
they go to the grc camp
and zemo tempts the kids with a turkish
delight which is what the white witch
used to tempt children with in the line
the witch in the wardrobe
jumped to a graveyard to see carly
getting her stash of super soldier serum
which comes in vials that look identical
to how they were in the first avenger
here they have a hawkwood conversation
in which a flag smasher says
he looked up to captain america his
entire life and in death
he ends up looking up to him too
and the dora melange arrived to take
zemo in and they disarm bucky
he ends up reconnecting it and winding
his arm similar to how he did in the
winter soldier
the dora melange also stamp on the
shield to pick it up
much like how steve did at the end of
the elevator fight in the aforementioned
movie
zemo escapes and is referred to as el
chapo who in real life was a drug dealer
that had tunnels built under his home
so that he could evade law enforcement
walker and battle star
go to the flag smash a hideout and they
enter kicking the door with pistols
drawn
much like how steve and the howling
commandos did in the first avenger
sam and bucky end up going there too
along with carly
and bucky does a knife spin at one point
during the fight
this is something that we saw him pull
off in the winter soldier and it's also
a call back to the first avenger
in that film when howard stark gave
steve the shield he said he would need
it as hydra wouldn't be coming at him
with a pocket knife
but bucky ended up doing that in his
following solo film
walker ends up killing the flag smasher
outside and though
typically a shield is used for defense
here it's used for offense
this shows that he's changed the meaning
of the shield much in the same way that
he's changed what captain america means
too
he's truly ruined it and seeing the
blood on it shows just how much its
legacy has been warped
the scene itself is a direct callback to
the ending of civil war
in which steve could have killed tony
with the shield but instead he drove
into the ark reactor
this showed that both had a choice to
kill their opponent but one decided that
if that's what it took to be captain
america that they didn't want to do it
steve left the shield behind whereas
walker straps it on tighter
showing where their two paths went in
different directions
people stand around and film the scene
on their phones which is a symbol of how
cell phones have been used recently to
capture police brutality
jump over to episode 5 and we watch as
walker flees the scene
during a moment he calms himself by
remembering the words of battle star
and this is similar to the comics in
which the character would actually talk
to his parents long after they died
much like lamar the murder of them sent
him off on a darker path
and the show has clearly changed things
up to mirror the original work
in the garage we get a lot of nods to
civil war including the scene in which
steve and sam managed to restrain bucky
similar this show that moment came off
the back of a rampage
carried out by a super soldier and even
the positioning of the characters
is exactly the same the framing for the
battle of civil war
2 reappears here with a two-on-one fight
involving bucky and a captain america
when bucky and jon fight one on one it's
very similar to the battle between the
former and steve in the street during
the winter soldier
some of the moves are even ripped right
out that movie making for an amazing
fight scene in the show
the battle ends with buggy dropping the
shield on the floor before walking off
much like how he and steve did at the
end of civil war
sam also tries to wipe the blood off of
it but it won't go
showing how much walkers tarnished its
reputation
walker returns to washington and has to
answer before a panel
which is similar to what happened in the
comics after he was defeated by steve
from here we meet valentina alegre de
fontaine who's wearing a long black coat
and recruiting super powered people this
of course mirrors the nick fury post
credits scene
at the end of iron man and she will
likely be reflecting him and creating
either the thunderbolts or the dark
avengers
we jump to the sokovian memorial and see
zemo taken to the raft
which we of course saw in civil war this
location is overseen by general ross
who in the comics helps to make the
aforementioned thunderbolts
they were originally led by baron zemo
so all the pieces are falling into place
and as always it's all connected
now we watch the community come together
to fix the boat up
and sam's nephews call him uncle sam
which is a bit on the nose we learn the
flag smashers plan is to attack the grc
meeting room
which seems to be heavily based on the
war room from dr strangelove
that was also parodied in watchmen
batroc meets carly at the bench and
gives her a suitcase
and this is actually the same location
that bruce willis and samuel l jackson
opened their own suitcase during die
hard with a vengeance
sam opens up his suitcase called that
because it has a suit in it
and we as an audience don't get to see
it which could be riffing on the one
from pulp fiction
we also see john walker building a new
shield and this moment is very similar
to when tony stark first created the
mark one armor
all the way back in the first iron man
movie now episode six is called one
world one people
the mantra of the flag smashes however
it's also a song
sung by femi cutie in it he puts across
the point that black people have been
held back by corrupt governments and
politicians
but that there is still hope people will
rise up against these forces
this is very much what the flag smashers
are trying to do with violence
but in the entry sam manages to change
things just by talking
sam and bucky travel to the grc building
and along the way the latter meets
sharon
who is wearing a prosthetic mask similar
the one that black widow wore in the
winter soldier
however it also holds another meaning as
it speaks to how her character is very
two-faced
sam arrives in the building and he says
that he's captain america
to which someone replies i thought he
was on the moon
this is obviously a call back to the
conspiracy theory from the first episode
and it could also be a nod to how steve
might be working with sword now
now sam fights with batrock in a moment
that's very similar to the opening of
the winter soldier
in which steve went head to head with
him in the street john walker arrives to
show that he's still worthy of being
captain america
and though he doesn't fight sam this
entire scene feels very akin to sam
wilson captain america
which had a moment in which walker tried
to publicly embarrass him in the street
so that people would lose faith in him
however walker has a moment in which he
can choose between saving people
or getting revenge and he does the right
thing from this point on
sam saves the day in a moment that's
very similar to iron man saving the
ferry in spider-man homecoming
because of his tech and the symbol that
he carries he's very much a combination
of both
iron man and captain america heck even
the helicopter scene in the sky reminded
me a lot of the rescue one from iron man
3
and sam getting hit with pipes before
being submerged in water
is very similar to tony being hit with
cars and landing in the sea when his
house was attacked
he chases the flag smashes which is when
we get a reveal
that sharon carter is the power broker
all along now in the basement
sam refuses to fight carly which is very
similar to steve at the end of the
winter soldier when he refused to fight
bucky
she's killed and then sam carries her
body in a moment
that very much echoes the painting of
cain and abel on the outside
bucky and walker capture the flag
smashes using the app
and shout out to the canadian lad for
pointing out that this is the same phone
that the woman earlier in the episode
gave him
she was clearly part of the villain team
and because the app was already
installed
they were able to track them samba
writes the senate and says that every
time he picks up the shield
he knows that there are millions who are
going to hate him which
is very much a comment on the reaction
that some fans have given the show
whenever it discusses things from a
certain viewpoint we then see the raft
namely one of the cells from civil war
and zemo reading the same book that he
had in his cell in episode 3.
this shows that he hasn't changed and is
very much the same as he was when we
first met him in this story
jump to washington to meet up with val
as well as us agent who has a new black
suit
which is ripped straight from the comics
interestingly his last line is i'm back
which is pulled from captain america 354
which was the issue that he returned in
sam takes isaiah to the smithsonian
and when they're walking through the
exhibit we see a shattered avengers logo
which looks very similar to one used in
trailers for endgame
the show ends with the title changing to
captain america and the winter
soldier and we go to the post-credits
scene with sharon now
starting an uprising in the government
similar to what hydra did with shield
now that ends the series and hopefully
they landed the bird
and that's terrible and i just want to
give a big shout out to all my easter
egg hunters out there like ryanairy
beyond epic superhero nexus new rock
stars canadian lad
real rejects 3c films and the person i
inevitably forgot
that i'll be kicking myself for as soon
as this video goes live
i'm sorry we have beef over me
forgetting to include you there and i
hate myself trust me i hate myself you
did a great job
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on this series and
if there's any easter eggs we missed
comment below and let me know and if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of all
the things you missed in mortal kombat
we've pointed out the coolest details
from the film so make sure you give it a
watch right after this
without the way thank you for checking
the video out i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace